good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy tuesday and
happy chanukah to all of our jewish
toasters hey jax how you doing i'm doing
really well i'm wearing vanity skins
today so i'm feeling great and just so
fabulous which is a feeling i haven't
had in a very long time but you are a
fabulous girl don't forget that no
somewhere deep inside of me i know
there's a fabulous girl begging to get
out yeah but it's just not her time well
i have to imagine you were inspired by
your outfit by our guest today who
joined us in studio you guys are gonna
quake first of all i was quaking it's
porsha williams real houses of atlanta
she's here talking about her new book
which is out today called the pursuit of
porsha
she wore the fendi skims complete
bodysuit which like very few people can
pull off she looked
radiant like it was a sight to see yeah
it was amazing she looked amazing the
interview is so good you guys are
seriously vibing i'm so happy for you
that you finally got to meet your hero
can i tell you how nervous i was like
maybe not nervous um intimidated yeah
she's like a force and she's really a
lovely lovely person and i just loved
talking to her and if you're watching on
youtube there's a separate video me and
portia just like chatting like a couple
gals and if you're listening to the
podcast just keep listening we've got a
great show for you guys today fast five
deer toasters and then we're gonna cap
off with the porsche interview and i'm
just excited for everyone to hear her
book
is really deep like it's not what you
would think a typical housewife um
memoir it's she's been through a lot
yeah and i just love her and she was so
like gorgeous and stunning and kind in
person and
it was great i'm excited for you guys to
see it we haven't interviewed like
people in studio in a while i mean we
had josh and shannon from and good carly
and erin carly and aaron but they're
like girly girls like that's
like but like a hard-hitting interview
no it has been a while especially
because of covet and now we're very
choosy about who comes in right so
definitely porsha is a great one yeah so
stay tuned for that but other than that
we've got a great show for you guys how
was your day how was your night i mean i
was thinking about you the whole night i
can't lie i was obviously thinking about
you girlies too uh at luke homes and you
know what i actually was fine i really
thought i was going to be crying i
really i like i planned and scheduled a
good obsession just like a woe is me cry
but no i watched and i was enjoying and
i watched every single slide i was just
like loving luke and this moment for him
and msg like what i would have given to
be a part of that crowd and just to like
see a crowd of that magnitude after two
years like it would have warmed my heart
so
but i was totally emotionally stable
okay good and hopefully we'll go two for
two tonight because you never know no i
think that if there was gonna be a night
where you would have had a breakdown it
would have been last night because last
night was like girly girl night you'd
love a gno yeah um
so i think you might be past like i
think i might have like gotten through
it and i think because i hyped it up so
much right it wound up being not as
tragic as i thought it was gonna be and
if anything you should just be like
so grateful right now that you don't
have legs that feel like jello a lower
back that doesn't exist that i do
anything yeah and a broken neck yeah no
all of those things just come with the
territory damn i mean
i feel like i actually like ran a
marathon i'm exhausted like not even
hungover i only had like three drinks
but
physically unwell yeah because that's
the type of music like when luke comes
out even his like slow songs you gotta
bang your head that's the sign of a good
concert can i tell you that i've been to
a lot of concerts in my life and i've
seen luke perform a bunch of times small
venues big venues because you know we've
been fans since the beginning
don't get her started
but i never saw anything like what i saw
last night i i and i'm talking about
that particular venue i've seen the
jonas brothers ariana grande john mayer
all great concerts
completely unparalleled
wow so he did the stage in the center
and he moves around he's a giver because
he's a giver and also everyone to have
the full experience of luke it allows
more people to have better seats have
better seats and also
sell more tickets that's like kevin hart
right exactly so that just makes it all
the more impressive he's first of all
for a country artist to sell at madison
square garden like in new york it's just
not heard of and for someone to do it
twice it's so
unbelievable so early in their career
yeah so i think like i was really
shepping a lot of nachos like early on
in the night because there wasn't an
empty seat in the house was he like
giving speeches throughout the night of
course usually i don't even like when
artists do that let alone if someone
were to put that on their story but i
was actually curious like what is luke
saying to the crowd yeah of course like
there was a part where we literally all
cried he was just talking about his
parents about how like oh my god i'm
gonna cry when i say it like they missed
out on so much
like working so hard so he could have
like the best possible life
and he just never in his wildest dreams
imagined that he would be here like he
used to live above a bar and he worked
at the bar and he got to play at the
barn for him that was like the dream the
dream and if it never got better than
that like he would have been so happy
doing that and he just i can't believe
how all of this happened so fast and he
was just very humble and very sweet and
he just kept saying like i can't believe
i'm here and in a million songs whatever
town he was talking about he changed it
to new york city and like people just
went [ __ ] wild oh and then he also
said you're gonna cry at this like
so he said like you know he grew up in
north carolina and he really didn't get
to see a lot of places
like travel wise until he was an adult
and he started like touring but one of
the places that he had been to um was
new york city he got to sing at carnegie
hall because
his high school like band teacher
who came to the show with her husband
had brought him to new york three times
and it was like such an impactful trip
for him and he got to sing at carnegie
hall and it was just like amazing and he
brought the teacher to the concert which
was so unbelievably sweet like we were
all joking like crying oh my god that is
so sweet
it was so sweet so we did and i actually
also
hate when people talk between no
but i needed to know how lucas feels
there are a few people who i'll allow it
taylor can say whatever she wants adele
was actually extremely funny when she
did it at her show she gave like a lot
of speeches she's like stand up stand up
x like ballads um and luke like i wanted
to know like how are you feeling yeah
and he was just so humble and so
grateful and it was so
like we were all
and he also said something at the end
that i thought was so interesting he's
like
you're not here to see me
i'm here to play for you it was just
like this whole thing about how like the
fans have changed his life he's ups like
i'm just [ __ ] obsessed with him you
know and he looked amazing you know
classic luke columbia shirt cowboy boots
red solo cup
and he was like encouraging the crowd
he's like i know it's a monday but and
by the way to sell out madison square
garden on a monday and tuesday it's just
it can't it's unbelievable and what i
thought was so interesting was like
first of all i never heard a stadium so
loud every person knew
every single song and usually there's
like a couple songs that everyone knows
and they like chant i would say it was
just as loud for his least popular song
as it was for his most popular song wow
yeah and oh my god one beer never broke
my heart i thought the place was going
to did you play it twice or your videos
your guys's videos were just like no he
played ones people were adding them a
different it was the last song okay and
it was like
my back is killing me worth it a hundred
percent worth it
so good
and i just felt very like proud and
happy for him you know in addition to
enjoying he's such a it was basically
like sitting at my computer listening to
itunes like his voice is amazing yeah
and i got to see ashley mcbride
i have a lot of thoughts because you
know i'm her number one fan but um i
literally didn't know any songs that
she's saying and like that made me
really upset because you realize you're
not her number one fan 100 okay um
because that would be really sad but
it's worth mentioning jackie
i never heard a voice like that in my
life like it's it made me and the songs
are so good it made me like want to
learn them you know when i was like it's
too late i don't know them um
so it wasn't like we learned them today
yeah it wasn't like the life-changing
experience i was looking for but i was
so happy to see my girl and she did sing
martha divine which is personally like a
song that will make me snap my neck so
good so all in all it was just like an
amazing evening filled with so much
talent and you'd love to see country
music in new york like we never get it
the one country station 947 has been
retired and now it's like an 80s station
so we get nothing we get scraps and we
finally got a big entree last night and
we have to thank luke holmes for that
so
so stunning it was really crazy to see
like so many country like hats and well
i was gonna say like when you were
looking around at machi at like these
new yorkers country fans and you're like
who are you guys like we should get
together sometime no i know it wasn't it
was like a different demographic than
i've seen at any concert like
they seem like city dwellers or they
came from the boroughs i think it was a
borough crowd like people coming in to
support luke because
you know people in new york don't dress
like that like they don't have cowboy
hats you know yeah and they don't have
hand-painted jackets with american flags
on them like it was so cute and that
wrote luke homes on the back and paint
it was so cute got it so the burrows
were coming out i mean i don't want a
stereotype but i i think it was a
borough crowd okay that's i wonder if
he's playing like new jersey connecticut
i mean they chanted usa like they don't
do that in the city that's a borough
thing yeah it is yeah um it was just an
incredible evening and if you have the
chance to see luca comes on tour like i
highly highly highly highly suggested
and there's another show at msg tonight
which i will be going to i don't know
how i'm going to do it like i feel like
the way people feel after they work out
like unwell yeah
okay well thank you for the recap i'm so
glad you guys had a great time and i'm
sorry we really missed you that i lived
to tell the tale yeah no we really
missed you i missed you guys
and everyone was asking it was toaster
central oh i was gonna say oh yeah and
then i feel like i could see toasters in
your videos like 100
and everyone was like
praying for jackie there was like a
communal actually luke led a prayer at
the beginning of the show
you know one of my really big fans
jackie can't be here tonight and he held
held a moment of silence which i thought
was really really kind of feminine it's
so really beautiful so generous
he loves you you know that's what helped
me make it through yeah the prayers
worked
his prayers were answered
okay well we're you're doing it all
again tonight very exciting i can't
believe it so we will get another recap
tomorrow i spent the evening editing the
new episode of the redheads which is
so good and so funny what is it oh it
drops on thursday and i like was so
tempted to drop it sooner because then
it's just like this is so hysterical and
it's here and it's ready but i'll wait
until [ __ ] thursday because like some
people haven't finished reading the book
yet and i don't want to stress them out
yeah i don't so and can you remind me is
it ever too late to become a redhead
never ever never is it too late because
you can pick up at any time the episodes
are just waiting for you they're
evergreen we don't really talk about
super tiny stuff it's just
we're in the books so
we've done 26 or 27 episodes so far so
that's 26 27 books that you that's crazy
like you read so much and none of them
are for the redheads so you've already
read 27 books this year yeah and it's
how do i know how many books i've read
this year oh do you did you do a
goodreads challenge give me your phone
no i i can tell you for sure i didn't do
a goodreads challenge
well you should have challenged yourself
this doesn't sound right no that's not
whatever you're looking at is not it
says i've done 15 of 50 books but i
never said 50 and i definitely read more
than 15. no i think that's right click
it
go to all the books that you read and
then scroll down to the bottom yeah i am
nothing seems to be missing but
that's right that's how you find it 15
is the is the like default goal
you know default that's insane like not
that you're expected to but if you were
setting goals that was my goal for the
year and i'm at 56.
i just started 50 likes
right
i feel like i just started my 57th book
last night that's [ __ ] crazy but last
year i read 65 books total so i'm not
gonna
i'm not gonna tie that
but hopefully i'll hit 60.
i just feel like this isn't right let me
see
no because like i'm looking at okay
verity it didn't come up in my thing but
i know i read verity this year you
probably didn't
these years are just like melting
together
but did i read in coven when did i start
reading i started reading that trip a
year ago to utah right so shouldn't all
my books can you just give me your phone
please you're killing me no i can't i
hate handing over myself please
just give it to me right like the
mother-in-law hold on you read the
mother-in-law this year because i read
it this year okay and it wasn't in my in
your goodreads
yeah there's something off with this i'm
telling you okay so can i i can help you
please okay fine okay
i'm just going to your
read books
then there's some i didn't finish
and when i started my goodreads this is
where i [ __ ] myself writing when i
started my goodreads i like wanted to
have a lot of books in my thing so like
i backlogged like a million books i've
read over the last like 25 years oh
that's fine like i entered added all of
these books that's okay because it helps
them curate your what you like so that
is totally fine okay
you also were reading on my account for
a while remember that oh that's why
oh my god yeah i have to start my
goodreads like fresh in 2022 because i
was so messy at the beginning of the
year connect your goodreads to your kids
i did i did really because otherwise if
you did that they would have the no but
see i probably read the mother-in-law on
your book your kindle got it so these
are okay so i've read 15 books
you know what i i read a lot of books i
read more than 15. okay you'll do a
count i will have to do it manually and
you'll let us know okay that's exciting
it looks like the first book that you
read on your own
it ends with us
yeah on my kindle yeah so
everything before that yeah okay i get
it i get it yeah confusing
hook up your goodreads to your kindle
and connect it with your amazon account
and you will be so well taken care of
yeah you know at peace you know i'm like
messy over here with my million kindle
accounts goodreads you're mussy i'm
speaking of stuffy is he in the news
today he's in the news today his trial
started yesterday as did gallan's we'll
talk about both even though like we're
not i mean it's only day one feels like
i might need this today my gavel yeah no
it's it's a day for justice but also
like these things take time yes of
course and we must not rush the justice
system it's not called the russia system
i know but it's also like will we get
justice that's the big question yeah it
doesn't feel like we will no especially
not in the lane no it's already like you
know jurors are getting surprised with
vacations can't can't can't be on the
jury and that's crazy and it's like a
closed court you know we are only
getting sketches which is crazy it
should be live and they're making her
look fabulous it's like a gorgeous
sketch like the kardashians are always
posting like their sketches
whoever is hayden christensen
whoever is sketching galain is extremely
flattering and i need to hire them
immediately okay well i guess without
further ado let's jump into the fast
side stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
today's episode is brought to you by
olive in june the olive and june nail
polish lasts over seven days and a dozen
on chip and their mani system is the
answer to salon perfect nails at home
with the mani system each other manicure
comes out to just two dollars which is
fabulous and out of control when you
think about how much you pay for a
manicure but the mani system from olive
and june is just something you really
really should have in your house it has
all the things you need for your nails
that you never have it has cuticle oil
it has nail files
obviously nail polish it just has
everything that you need you're always
like running around your house like do
you have a nail file if you have the
manny system you'll always have it and
you have salon perfect nails at home for
a much much cheaper price their nail
polishes are fabulous and they are
they last over seven days
which doesn't even happen at the nail
salon so
it's
it's crooked what's going on at the
salons um the system comes with all the
tools that you need in one box it's only
five steps it comes with a poppy that's
a patented brush handle that you put on
the olive and you nail polish bottles
that makes it really easy to paint both
of your hands
keeps your arms steady it's also just
really affordable with the six polishes
it breaks down to two dollars of
manicure when you use to spend just 35
dollars for one gel manicure
the polish is amazing this is a great
stocking stuffer for your mom your
grandma anyone who likes to do their
nails um so check it out get 20 off your
first mani system when you use promo
code toast at oliveinjune.com again 20
off your first manny system when you use
promo code toast at olive and june.com
your new nail life is here
thank you claudia it's a pleasure
okay our first story galaine maxwell
trial started yesterday the prosecutor
said she's quote a predator who served
up young girls to be abused that is true
that is what she did and that is who she
is galen maxwell listened as a crowded
courtroom heard alert allegations that
she and jeffrey epstein quote lured
victims with promise of a brighter
future and then destroyed them she is
labeled as a dangerous predator who
served up the girls for sexual abuse a
court was told yesterday the british
socialite was billionaire pedophile
jeffrey epstein's second in command and
lured vulnerable teenagers for him to
assault a jury in new york heard the
courtroom was passed so it's in new york
it's in it's in new york and it's like
you can get a seat in there but the
people who were in there
started getting in line at 5 00 a.m in
the freezing cold to get a seat so
that's going to be a no for me but we
got to get some seats yeah so that would
be really crazy
so yesterday was day one of the trial
prosecution opened defense galena's
defense is saying that she's being
blamed for like jeffrey's crimes they
compared her to eve of adam and eve what
nerve the woman being blamed for the
sins of the man oh you know what though
we're living in such crazy times it just
might it might fly and then uh the
prosecution is really
she's really seen as a proxy for jeffrey
because we can't get to jeffrey i mean
that is true like i think we're pinning
this whole thing on galen when she's
definitely responsible but not as
responsible as a person who actually did
it and she's all we have left she's our
only child but that's just too bad for
delaney it's too [ __ ] bad right so
that's where they're coming from
prosecution and defense and then
yesterday we heard from one of the
pilots of the lolita express who was
testifying as to what he saw in the
years that he worked on the plane said
more personal than business obviously
yeah
oh that is so interesting i mean i have
to say
i'm worried because it's not a terrible
defense
like it is when you think about it like
now we're all galen galee and galen when
we were a year ago all jeffrey jeffrey
jeffrey yeah but jeffrey's not around so
we have to be galen galen galen yeah
we're like projecting all of our jeffrey
stuff on to glean and i'm not sorry
about it don't get me wrong but in the
court of law like it might it might hold
up your saying not hold up but i do
think it might get her like a lesser
sentence i also want to especially when
um you know there are a lot of people
invested in protecting right what's to
come out so that was my other question
was did she strike any sort of deal i
had heard like a while ago people said
she was gonna like sing for her supper
you know rat everyone out just to get
her self-immunity but it seems like
maybe she didn't do that because she's
like fully on trial now well maybe she
will share those things those things
maybe that's why it's not being live
streamed and why it's a closed court
situation i am so suss about this whole
thing like i am questioning everything
yeah no i hate to be like such a
conspiracy theorist no but if there's
ever a time to put on your you know
conspiracy helmet this is it when there
are just so many lies that are just
thrown around and then and we're meant
to believe them when it's just so
obvious it's impossible to not look for
other answers no and like i feel like
that netflix documentary opened up a
tiny tiny bit of like who the powerful
people
were like that what's that guy's name
that was in the documentary the
victoria's secret guy his name starts
with an l
it's like a a girly it's gonna say it's
a woman's name yeah leslie leslie yeah
like where let's follow up on that you
know follow up on that girly girl right
we
we opened it up and the netflix dog
wechsler
yes well very good i don't even want to
say it i was also gonna say les moonves
but that's the guy from cbs but he's
also problematic also problematic see
all i'm saying is like we should know
this like we are pop culture experts but
nobody's talking about it and they're
just brushing it aside like okay [ __ ]
elaine for sure but like [ __ ] all the
other guys like galain
what's the word i'm looking for um
like set up the interactions okay but
these disgusting old men like committed
the crimes as well worse than galen
yeah worse than galen like so i would
like some accountability on the leslie's
uh of the world yeah i i agree i don't
know if that's happening so it seems
like it's not it seems like this case is
fading into a relevancy faster than i am
a hundred percent and that's really fast
yeah no that's really fast and we're
going to do our best to stay abreast and
keep you abreast uh because someone's
got to do it so i should do a lane
update daily daily yeah a lot of people
have been sending me stuff please keep
sending um and send it to your friends
and family too stir the pot yeah we need
like this has to be a boots on the
ground like
grassroots movement like the free
britney movie and it can be done also
the jeffrey epstein didn't kill himself
movement like how many times are they
going to tell him that he did no if you
like posted a meme in the last two years
jeffrey epstein didn't kill himself like
it is also your responsibility
to keep your friends family and peers
abreast on the lane maxwell of it all
okay yeah we will not stop until
justice is served
yeah but even yesterday there was some
like jury stuff happening and what i
thought was so interesting is that one
juror was excused over a vacation that
they couldn't reschedule that it was a
surprise trip from the panelist's spouse
okay i mean like that's possible now or
someone's buying someone a trip and to
take them off the panel well here's the
thing like does gelani have any money
because
what i remember from the netflix
documentary was that like she said her
father was like a really rich printing
magnet like he was but then he like went
broke and she was like living off of
jeffrey so i don't know if she has tons
of money to spend on lavish gifts for
jurors no but if she's going to protect
certain people oh yeah then they will be
paying for lavish gifts so if you bribe
a juror
does the juror get in trouble too
i would think so they're just like right
it's so unethical yeah
whatever we'll see if you were a juror
you think you could be bribed i
definitely could no if i'm in that box
justice must be served yeah i guess like
i joke but like if i was handling a
serious case and nothing could stop me
from keeping that jury box and like
after days of jury selection where
they're asking you so many questions and
you really have to like look inward and
like
decide like how you actually feel you
take it so [ __ ] seriously can i tell
you what if i was on trial
and we weren't sisters obviously i would
very much want for you to be my juror i
think you're very
headstrong and very reasonable and very
rational and like logical i think you
would make a great juror perhaps a rural
juror as well thank you so much right
now i would be an urban juror yeah but
if i were to ever move i could be a
rural juror and i just hope that
whatever happens in this lifetime i
never end up on a jury because like when
you know when you get in that room
you're so wishy washy yeah no see we get
in the room and everyone's telling their
sides and like someone's siding like i
think he did it because x y i'm like
totally but then someone else is like no
i don't think this man did it because x
y and z and then i'm like you know what
you sound like you're you're on to
something it's like have you ever read
spineless have you ever read or seen 12
angry men
no but i saw 12 angry men inside amy
schumer
got it well it's the premise is like a
jury and the case really seems like
science clever they're just you know
going through the motions of jury things
this is me remembering it from like 15
years ago but this is what i glean and
there's one juror who's like the
contrarian and it's like let's just play
out if it wasn't this guy and he
obviously ends up being right and
spoiler alert yeah no there's some major
issues and you know 12 i don't know why
they're 12 angry men um because being a
juror sounds like torture yeah no you
can't go to work can't see your family
there's not great lunch options and if
you're in like a high profile jury case
like this is what i remember from
watching oj like the jurors are tortured
like they have to stay in a hotel they
have to eat their meals together they
can't have like books magazines can't
watch tv they literally just stare at
the wall while they're not in the jury
no and they're also tortured by the
media yeah and but then also afterwards
it's like they all get book deals so
like it's a
it's a give and take yeah no it's it's a
tough spot to be in and speaking of some
more legal news jesse smollett's who
musty
justice moulier's
trial started yesterday and his lawyers
claiming he was a real victim during
opening statements the amount that i
like despised this man is unparalleled
like it's interesting you know what's so
what i didn't think about it's like when
you go to a trial it's like everybody
has to come up with like their story
yeah a defense yeah and i didn't never
thought that his defense would be
you know probably yeah is that what he
said yeah that's what he's saying that
he was a victim of a crime um
prosecutors said that he staged a hate
crime during the opening arguments of
the trial in chicago and
he is saying no i didn't like i was
actually because he was still like he's
doubling down
he's doubling down yes exactly i guess
that's an interesting legal route to
take but i just think we were just
talking about this because right before
this um article the last time moosie was
in the news was he like hit a red carpet
he was his first red carpet appearance
um post you know faking a hate crime
and we were allegedly allegedly and you
were like i mean who was inviting him to
red carpets and i just thought it was so
funny because i need you guys to go look
up this red carpet picture it's not like
a red carpet like at a fancy gala it's a
full red carpet like in the middle of
the street like it's not you anything's
a red carpet if you make it one yeah no
if you have a little spray paint right
like it's just not what you think it is
so at first i saw that news article and
i was like he's seriously out about
working like this man wasted police
resources committed a hate crime i'm
sorry faked a hate crime i'm like we are
really out here like putting him on red
carpets again but then i saw the picture
and i was like oh no we're fine oh okay
yeah no that's what you told me but the
headline was like just hitting the red
carpet and i was like
what no it was shocking if you know what
you know what's so like
this is like
this is a bad thing for jesse because
it's like so embarrassing like you just
got caught lying you know i don't think
there's anything
it's like mortifying
yeah well he his defense attorney is
saying that the real crime was committed
against the actor by the two brothers
from nigeria who he had met on the
senate empire who attacked him because
they quote did not like him as a person
so remember when we were reporting the
story
as it unfolded and it was like there was
the check that he wrote them yeah of
course like literally plain as day just
like the check here and in the memo it
was like for the staged hate crime
but now he's saying it was
real like they really why did he pay
them
that's what you know the courts will
have to
suss out
i just can't i mean this is so obviously
like not a real crime that he committed
and honestly the fact that he's doubling
down is just
it's just like offensive to people who
are actually victims of hate crimes like
it happens all the time every day and
now you're out here like making a
mockery of the justice system and it
ain't cool yeah so we'll keep you posted
on that one as well that was such a
crazy time do you ever think about that
it was a crazy it was a crazy
rollercoaster of emotions because when
it happened it was like so horrible like
imagine that actually happening like
some they threw a noose around his neck
allegedly poured bleach on him a
horrible horrible horrible hate crime
unfolded like who figured out well i
think well
once the brothers were taken into
custody they were released after they
told the police that jesse had paid them
to stage the attack because uh and they
snitched because they were unhappy with
their salary so it started to unfold
like in the very quickly yeah
got it so like then the police had like
cause yeah and i think that's something
that we're adding up got it okay that
was just i'll never forget where i was
when i was like found out that was not
real you know i don't remember where it
was me neither but i remember uh talking
about on the toast but you'll never
forget the moment yeah yeah the feeling
the feeling of being like what the [ __ ]
yeah shocked yeah agreed
well are you ready for our next story if
it's a story that's brought to you by
jenny kane yes it is when it comes to
getting dressed jenny kane believes in
the one thing the art of simplicity with
the focus on comfort quality and
timeless design jenny cane makes pieces
that truly never go out of style
curated stylish staples that work with
everything in your closet the simplest
way to put look put together in an
instant they offer elevated basics that
focus on comfort without sacrificing
style you might already have a favorite
sweater or pair of shoes but if it
doesn't make you say i'll never take it
off then this is not jenny kane okay i
have a bunch of jenny cane products but
i think by far my favorite is the
cardigans that i have it's so true like
during the winter how many sweaters can
you have you want to invest in good ones
and you can style them differently but
jenny kane just makes great simple
basics so you can wear a bunch of
different ways a bunch of different
times no one's gonna realize you're
wearing the same sweater you know and
it's always better like with sweaters i
believe to invest in good ones they're
not itchy you can take care of them and
it's just a good piece to have and
you'll have it winter after winter it's
not like you've been doing after season
you have to buy a new sweater every year
every time it gets cold so jenny kane is
a great place if you want to start
investing in good winter
pieces they offer so many different
things the cocoon cardigan um crew neck
and now they offer it in a crop style is
one of the best-selling sweaters they
have and it's a perfect thing for a
holiday wish list um they also have
a mock clog and shearling lined mule
which is the perfect shearling shoes
which are super in style now you can
stay warm and stylish with a touch of
suede and shearling find your forever
pieces at jennycaine.com and get 15 off
your first order when you use code toast
at checkout that's
j-e-n-n-i k-a-y-n-e dot com promo code
toast that's a good promo code great for
gifts and don't miss out because for
gifts it's a it's a substantial
percentage okay our next story is a
little more crime news wow we're just
feeling quite judicial today or just
it's very criminal out here totally
bradley cooper recalls being held up at
knife point on the subway in new york
city
bradley cooper revealed that he was held
up at knight point on new york city
subway enroute to pick up his daughter
in 2019. he was on dak shepard's podcast
armchair expert and he said quote i used
to walk around new york city all the
time with these headphones on this was
pre-pandemic i was on the subway at 11
45 to pick up leah his daughter downtown
at russian school and i got held up at
knifepoint he said it was pretty insane
i realized i had gotten way way too
comfortable in the city yeah he said my
guard was down i was all the way at the
end of the subway innately i would just
go all the way down to the end i felt
somebody coming up i thought oh they
want to take a photo or something as i
turned i'm up against the post like it's
the french connection or some [ __ ] and i
turned i look down and i see a knife the
actor described the weapon as a nice
knife with some history behind it and
because he had his headphones in he was
listening to music when he was
approached he joked that the scary
incident was scored like there was
that's funny musical score behind it he
said i can't remember what i was
listening to i look up i see the
person's eyes and i'm taken by how young
they are yeah
he said despite never being just despite
being taught to never run if approached
by someone with a weapon the star
instinctively bolted for the exit of the
station he said i just started booking
just started running i jumped over the
turnstile hit around the white tiled
entrance to the subway and took my phone
out he jumped over running away i took a
photo of him then i chased him up the
stairs he started running up 7th avenue
i took two more photos of him and then
he flagged down two police officers to
show them photos of the culprit imagine
you're just a common criminal you're on
the subway doing your thing
and you roll up on some guy who's
obviously not paying attention like the
perfect target yeah and it's bradley
cooper how exciting i wonder if he ever
had a moment if he knows his work if he
had a moment of recognition i feel like
now no
you know what i i will never and this
might be like the most unpopular thing
i've ever said like i will never
understand the richest people in the
world who like still take the subway
like if i was bradley cooper i would be
flown in a helicopter everywhere like
that's the point of being a celebrity
like you don't have to do things that
other people have to do like i'll never
understand that like andy cohen takes a
subway to work but you know what
actually when andy cohen takes a subway
i understand it like he does morning
radio it's like rush hour and he's going
from downtown to siriusxm which is like
60 blocks that i actually understand
because it is the most efficient way of
getting around but i don't know if i was
bradley cooper i had to pick my daughter
from school i'm like tally up the
chauffeur yeah my jeeps
[Laughter]
bring the car around no literally like
julio get the stretch like
i'll never understand that like and
that's me maybe just being like a
materialistic [ __ ] but i just don't i
don't see that i don't agree with it and
i just think it's psychotic yeah well
he's definitely going to be more aware
now yeah no that's a thing now like you
can not wear your headphones on the
subway no and just like one because
someone might steal this headphones
right off your head right but also
because like you got to be aware of your
surroundings yeah no you can't just like
be in a bubble i think that the new york
city uh bus routes are the most
undervalued public transportation they
have amazing air conditioning for the
most part they're pretty updated there's
just so much traffic so like you're not
getting anywhere yeah but they get all
those lanes that's true and they get all
those lanes
if you think about the people who take
buses it's really the elderly because
they they can't really walk down steps
to go to the subway and it's just a
really nice it's a nice crowd it's a
nice crowd a great way of getting around
and i just think more people should be
taking the bus i'm being dead serious
yeah but if you are going like long
distances
inter borough cross town like
you know good luck on the bus good yeah
diagonally yeah if you have nowhere to
be take the bus
it's just like a leisurely like i used
to take the bus on the way home from
school in high school because like who
cares when you get home you can't take
the bus to school you'll never get
you'll never make it you'll never get
there no
are you ready for our next story yeah
rihanna has been named a national hero
by barbados that is so cute quote may
you continue to shine like a diamond
rihanna was honored by her home country
during a ceremony to mark the barbados
splitting from the uk to become a
republic yes so yesterday barbados was
in the news as they have split from the
uk
queenie is no longer head of state for
the for barbados so that means queen
elizabeth is no longer
rihanna's queen
i guess not oh that's correct and now
and also they named rihanna as a
national hero by the prime minister in
barbados in a ceremony marking the
country split from the uk to become its
own republic love that for them get your
independence girl but if i was a
republican i would want to be with the
queen but that's just me because i'm
such an egg kind
that's kind of a contradiction because i
can't believe in public okay if i was in
a lab if you establish your own country
yeah i would want to be like a part of
the united kingdom i don't know there's
so much drama in the eu like brexit i
don't know well they brexited
yeah so you might not have to associate
with these no i just mean they have all
these things you know like brexit
pounds like i don't know i think i would
want to retain my independence as well
belong to no man you are an independent
queen that's what i'm saying and now so
is barbados happy for them know that i
am in a video of this ceremony shared by
the guardian rihanna walked up to um
these stories today are like so serious
like crime politics republics everything
of the sort she's wearing bottega orange
gown she's looking so good looking
incredible
she um do you think she's ever gonna
make music ever again i just feel like
actually no
would you
like you're making billions with your
makeup that you're so passionate about
people can't get enough of it the only
way that she would or should make music
is if she has a song to sing a song in
her heart you can always tell when
people release music because they like
think it's time not because they like
had something to say yeah like adele has
something to say she waited six years to
have something to say
i agree and some like so i think rihanna
will put out music when she has
something that she can't keep in any
longer i know but you know in the time
that we've missed out on her music she's
been through breakups makeups like lots
of things i think she definitely has a
rolodex of emotions to sing about
perhaps or maybe she's going to channel
it elsewhere into fashion and beauty
yeah like i just want to say that
running joke is always like rihanna
where's the album
i'm perfectly at peace with rihanna the
business woman like i actually don't
need any more pop stariana like i love
this growth for her i and i love that
for you i just want to let you know
every time she comes up you do ask about
new music
well that's just because i'm on the
pulse of what's going on and like that's
the running joke everyone with rihanna's
like new music question mark and i just
want to say like i don't need new music
from rihanna because i love businessman
queen rihanna yeah and like national
hero queen of barbados the republic
so what was it before
a democrat
you know like before if it wasn't a
republic it was just like
a country
yeah it was always a country but it was
part of um
you know the
european union
they talk about it in the crown the uh
commonwealth the commonwealth do you
think this is going to be like a trend
perhaps
does that mean like no queenie has got
to make some drastic moves just have
charles killed
totally kidding that's not a funny joke
um but she's got to do something drastic
and charles ain't the answer is what i'm
saying right right i think charles like
there's four nails in the coffin charles
is the fifth and that's the last one you
know
we got a
gotta do something okay charles keeps me
up at night yeah no i don't think i'm
the only one i think queen is definitely
kept up at night by her moronic son
who just cannot stop stepping in [ __ ]
you know a hundred percent
are you ready for a fifth and final
story
it's the final story
hopefully fingers crossed um okay the
fifth and battle story is brought to you
by legacy box which is first of all the
brand that people are always asking me
like what's the one with the videotapes
listen up and it's a great gift for
someone in your life and it's a holiday
season so legacy box of course you know
the service that couldn't be more easier
where you send in old home movies and
photos and they will get to work
creating a digital collection that
legacy box will store on a thumb drive a
dvd or the cloud
plus they're having a cyber week sale
and you can have everything preserved at
a fraction of the regular price
so legacy box is super professional each
item that you send into them whether
it's old vcrs photos they are hand
digitizing everything you send them they
have a team of over 200 trained
technicians right in the usa they have
been an industry leader in
professionally digitizing family
memories for over a decade it's easy
it's safe they keep you informed the
whole time they have a bar-coded online
tracking system you get 12 emailed
updates along the way it's just a
pleasure to work with them and do not
miss out on their cyber week sale so
legacy's boxes cyber week sale is here
they are giving our listeners the best
deal of the year
legacybox.com toast for an incredible 65
off any sized legacy box so that's
legacybox.com
toast for 65 off do not wait this deal
will not last long legacybox.com
okay our fifth and final story finally
some mindless celeb news toast
christine quinn and emma hernan selling
sunset mystery man has been revealed
this is so interesting if you watch
selling sunset christine and emma talk
about this guy who they both dated five
years ago he seems like so irrelevant he
seems like a myth and he's yeah it seems
like he just like fled the country and
we couldn't ask him a question if we
tried turns out his name is peter
cornell and he works at the oppenheim
group he did work at the oppenheim group
and he still works at the oppenheim
group he's the director of the sports
and entertainment division of the
oppenheim group and i'm assuming he sits
upstairs no literally while they argue
about him downstairs the fact that like
we now have all this information yet i
feel more confused than ever is beyond
bizarre
why
okay the fact that this man works at the
oppenheim group is the dumbest thing
i've ever heard like bring him on the
show right like he could have cleared up
so much also it's rumored and there's
pictures that he and emma like are still
dating yeah no well they're dating
they're together she's not engaged she
didn't wear a ring she said on the show
that she's single yet he proposed to her
two months after the christine thing so
they were engaged and it looks like
emma's lying too it's the whole thing
stinks stupid it's so stupid and i just
cannot believe that this man has just
been in earshot the entire time
when he could have cleared up so much
stuff except i don't even want to hear
from him because i know that he'll
probably say that christine is crazy
right because he's because she's emma
and he's
he's with emma and christine is like a
crazy ex-girlfriend doesn't mean that
she wasn't your ex-girlfriend but i feel
like
i don't i don't need to hear what he has
to say especially if
he's dating emma and then even the
pardon selling sunset when christine was
like i drove by his house and her car
was in the driveway like what yeah
like random [ __ ] things like small
little
crumbs of weirdness yeah so this guy's
cute he is super cute he's obviously a
businessman bow did you see the picture
of him and christine walking the red
carpet at the hot tub time machine
premiere i did see that picture did you
see the picture of him and chris
humphries in the street
i did that's what i said both follow not
skinny
no that's where i saw it i texted it to
you oh
i said the x and chris oh you did send
it to me yeah because i was googling it
i just assume i see everything i'm not
scared of enough i sent it to you i got
okay i found it on google because i
wanted to know more about this man and i
guess since he works in sports like
right that's the chris humphries
connection what is the sports department
at
a real estate agency look like like you
work with athletes but christine
christelle was working with athletes
maybe like doing commercial real estate
in the athletic department yeah i don't
know like gyms at schools sure
maybe you know he did the deal for
crypto.com stadium got it
stuff like that well
um i feel like with more information
i've never felt more confused
yeah i just this was really shocking and
it just goes to show how even more
fraudulent this season was like i
thought this man you know probably
didn't even have social media didn't
have a phone jet it off with
and he was unreachable no he's upstairs
he's upstairs listening to the girls
talking about him insane
insane also i really feel that the
oppenheim group needs a new office that
was like a uh
they're running out of desks they're
running out of desks they don't have
like a conference room and like they
have their team meetings everyone's like
flying off the couch and you're selling
millions and millions of dollars of
homes allegedly get an office get a
conference room get a place with enough
desks for everyone yeah but it's like
i would say 360 days out of the year
those women don't show up and in those
days obviously the office suffices
obviously yeah um so those were the past
five you feel as though you needed to
know them definitely um we have deer
toasters which is our advice segment so
if you ever want to write in to your
toasters it's dear toasters at
cheapbound.com we will keep your name
anonymous you can write in about
anything if you need some advice for me
two favorite gals who seem to have their
heads on relatively
straight perhaps first up
oh my throat hurts from talking last
night from screaming hi jackie and
claudia i'm a relatively new toaster and
i love you both so much
my best friend came home hysterical last
week because her boyfriend thought he
had a uti i told her symptoms
sorry he told her his symptoms and they
also happened to be the same symptoms as
chlamydia she starts freaking out
because she thinks somehow she could
have gave it to him so she went to get
an std test meanwhile he wasn't
concerned it was an std so he didn't get
tested weird because he was the one with
the symptoms anyway
she gets a call from the guy now today
and was positive for chlamydia side note
they've been dating since january 2021
and she has not cheated on him she also
got an std test in march in 2021 and it
was negative
she told him she dusted positive and he
turns it around on her and is trying to
gaslight her saying he's never gotten an
std test and it could have been dormant
from a previous relationship let me
remind you she tested negative in march
and they started dating in january and
had unprotected sex for three months so
it would have shown a positive
regardless of the first initial test
back in march so his claim of it being
dormant is invalid he keeps gaslighting
her and trying to make her think it was
her but all facts lead to him cheating
on her she's convincing herself he
didn't cheat and it couldn't have been
her
when it literally is impossible for it
to be her because she didn't cheat
anyways i'm literally so [ __ ]
frustrated because she's saying she
doesn't care and isn't gonna break up
with him as long as the std is gone
which will be in like two days because
she gets medicine but the girl he
literally cheated on you but girl he
literally cheated on you and got caught
red-handed what the [ __ ] i need advice
because i literally can't wrap my head
around the fact that she still wants to
be with him and i refuse to be around
this man and he always is at our
apartment i also refuse to go to their
wedding if they ever get to that point
she wants me to be made of honor is it
wrong that i'm so [ __ ] annoyed and
frustrated with my best friend help no i
would be so frustrated two things here
one if you like if you want to try your
hand at making her see the light like a
doctor can tell you
you know does chlamydia lay dormant no i
don't and i don't i'm not a doctor by
the way but i'm pretty sure it's not
something that is dormant and then pops
up like if if she didn't cheat there's
only one way she could like i think a
doctor needs to make it clear to her the
timeline the chain of events and how
this std works
two there is a chance
if she's really being this headstrong
about the fact that that she wants to
stay with him there is a chance that she
cheated on him right and she doesn't
want to tell you and doesn't and is just
going to let the whole thing go
i don't think that's it but it's
possible i agree and also at some point
like you gotta let like dumb [ __ ] be
dumb like the facts have been
very clearly explained to her she's like
living in an alternate universe and
you've done what you can but like you're
your own person she's her own person
she's making a very bad decision and
sometimes you got to let people learn
[ __ ] the hard way because if you cheat
on her he will obviously cheat on her
again maybe she'll get an std maybe she
won't maybe it'll be worse than
chlamydia chlamydia is easily i mean
obviously getting an std is not ideal
chlamydia is probably one of the better
ones you know get a medicine and it's
over so i just think
you got to let people make their own
mistakes sometimes and it sounds like
you've done all you can
and she refuses to see anything other
than her boyfriend like being a great
man honestly the possibility that she
cheated on him sounds more and more
likely yeah because
that would be
incredibly forgiving if she just doesn't
even want to make not even like she's
going to take him back like he didn't
even go through the ringer yeah you know
yeah like there were no consequences for
his actions not one none not one none
zero zero zero done
so that's really tough i would
understand distancing yourself from
someone who would make such poor
decisions because then that just like it
affects other elements of their life
like they obviously have bad judgment
you don't have to say like right now i
won't be your maid of honor obviously
these two are still dating and i don't
think they're getting married anytime
soon it doesn't seem like they're in a
rush but you know just go with how you
feel you don't want to go to dinner with
her tonight because you're not in the
mood to see her like
be annoying defend this
man don't go to dinner like you don't
have to make such sweeping
generalizations that like we're not
going to be friends anymore we're not
going to be in your wedding just take it
one day at a time for yourself for
yourself like of course it's annoying to
be around someone who's like being
annoying and stupid so don't be around
them right and then inevitably your
relationship will change and you
probably and you won't be made of honor
yeah all right next one good morning
jackie and claudia my friend introduced
me to the toast a few years ago and i've
never missed an episode since thank you
both so much for being you
i've wanted to get back into gymnastics
oh a gymnast you know i used to do
gymnastics with paul rudd
i wanted to get back into gymnastics
over the last year and i finally found a
coach a man who's willing to take a 27
year old who is new to gymnastics
i'm a dancer and a dance teacher so i
can do some things already but
definitely need a coach on helping with
backflips etc good for you girl my
husband is irritated and asks a million
questions when i go once a week i can
tell he's very jealous and from what he
said he doesn't like the idea of someone
touching me spotting me when i do a flip
my husband even told me he can
he can teach me gymnastics but he has
never taken gymnastics in his life he
said he would just youtube the things
that's actually sweet
i'm torn i really want my husband to be
comfortable and happy with the situation
however i've never done anything to make
him not trust me so i feel very torn i'm
willing willing to give it up for my
husband but also wanting to be better my
gymnastics still skills would love your
advice sincerely a toast this is a
really interesting predicament and i
guess it doesn't happen very often
because most even you know the most
seasoned gymnasts they do stop
by 27. right so to pick up gymnastics at
27 and you're you know when you take
james as a kid you're not married yeah
but it is you know a contact sport i
don't know i just love that you're like
in this season of your life trying new
things and it's like a fit you're
feeling good you're feeling healthy and
i just don't feel like we should
discourage that like it's important to
have hobbies it's important to be
passionate about things and i think your
husband like really needs to get over
this
yeah like definitely it's weird like
they stick your hand their hand like
between your legs while you're like
flipping it's weird
but it's not nefarious uh until it is
but it's not nefarious
yeah but you might fall in love when
he's like you know really getting in
there and if it is nefarious just the
you know the spotting in general
then
then it's the fairies with the kids too
like when k when any then any gymnastics
coach is nefarious
like at any age
yeah but no it's not nefarious right now
you're saying yeah
and also it's like people go have
personal trainers and it's a contact
it's true
and
you ever see a personal trainer like
stretch a client afterwards it's very
important right and if the husband was
like you can't do that anymore like
that's a little
yeah i think you gotta say your husband
down and tell him to [ __ ] off yeah and
and i like this for you i love that
you're trying new things this is not
something i've ever heard of someone
just wanting to get into gymnastics
i'm inspired too and
i i do i'm i do understand why your
husband like might look at it maybe
invite him to a class so he could see
like we're really just spotting and
trying the fact that he said he would
teach her like you're learning on
youtube he sounds so sweet i don't i
don't think he has a nefarious intention
i don't want to dismiss like how he's
feeling you know no but you got to sit
him down and be like this is something
i'm like having fun doing like i need
you to get off my ass but maybe it means
he comes with you and that way like you
won't take up gymnastics you can be
insured that nothing nefarious is
happening i like that and then you're
doing something together it brings you
closer yeah very good that's good advice
okay but good luck don't give up the
gymnast no lifestyle it's for you that's
so cool
all right third and final
hello ladies oh gee breath are here
never wavered and my absolute love for
you guys thank you my best friend of
over 12 years sarah moved to new york
city to be closer to me about two years
ago naturally i introduced her ooh this
sounds bad yeah naturally i introduced
her to a lot of my friends who i had
made since moving here we would go out a
lot and then started there then there
started a pattern of her getting
absolutely blackout falling over and
sometimes getting us kicked out of bars
someone writing this in about me
the next morning she would show no
remorse which i found to be kind of
weird like where's your anxiety i have
no issue with occasionally blacking out
but it got to a point where my
boyfriend's friends and co-workers
didn't want me to bring her around
because she was so chaotic and it was
embarrassing because she's like a sister
to me i made a comment to her that
blacking out was starting to be a lot
she then sent me a text the next day
pretty much telling me everything she
doesn't like about me i'm too judgmental
and apparently i only care about myself
i only tried to patch things up
but she didn't want to be friends
anymore shortly after that i started to
notice my girlfriends weren't reaching
out to me and i was seeing on social
media that they were hanging out with
sarah i didn't understand why and even
tried reaching out but received no
response fast forward a year i still see
pictures sometimes of all my old friends
and sarah hanging out and it makes me
cry i just think wow these people really
didn't care about me at all and the tick
tock sound am i the villain i've since
made some new friends but i'm so
self-conscious about [ __ ] it up or
them deciding one day that they don't
want to be friends with me anymore you
girls seem to be very sure of yourself
so how do you not let those things
bother you how do i be myself around my
new friends but also make sure i'm a
person worth keeping around sincerely a
sad lonely toaster ps thank god for the
toaster community because that's how i
made the new friends oh okay i think
that like you're just overthinking it a
little bit you know like for the most
part just be like if you really just be
yourself people like you but if you like
are being very
like calculated almost about how you're
be how you're coming off people just
might find you like annoying and
calculated you know yeah they might
sniff that out but here's my question
how come her old friends just because
she got into
a tiff with sarah how come her old
friends are no longer friends with her
the way that i perceived it was like
sarah like co-opted the friendships oh i
mean maybe poisoned if no offense this
blackout queen was able to co-opt your
friendships then they weren't strong to
begin with also if she really is that
annoying sloppy and embarrassing then
like her true colors will show and she's
their problem now and you just have to
wait because at the end like
it always the truth always comes to
light people can't hide who they are
and you know i don't think sarah had
this to like come to jesus moment where
she realized that she was like a drunk
embarrassment no because she would have
then taken your words a little better so
just let her do her thing that will play
itself out in the meantime focus on not
only like you finding friends that like
you but you liking them too and then
it's natural and then you can be
yourself and you don't have to worry
like that's true you don't don't just
worry about everyone else liking you
like what do you want what do you like
who do you want to spend time with wow i
really think that was very beautifully
sad i don't really have anything to add
thank you yeah but i think for the most
part like just relax
yeah it's gonna be okay yeah plus do you
have your mans yeah
did you say she had a man's yeah
boyfriend yes and that's why like and he
was embarrassed by by sarah being an
animal yeah that's really bad yeah when
like the boyfriends are saying something
co-workers cause like men are animals
like they don't even notice anything 100
like for me i like judge everyone ben
wouldn't know if somebody came and took
a dump in the middle of the bar like
he's like oh last night was fun yeah i
think there was a dump
so yeah like just be chill
and it'll come don't force it you know
yeah take the pressure off um okay so
those are the deer toasters to your
toasters at gmail.com if you ever want
to write in and if you've written in and
we've read your read your prompt on air
give us an update let us know how things
went we would love love love to hear
from you guys
now it is time
for portrait williams which i'm so
thrilled about and our segment with
porcha williams is brought to you by
shipstation figuring out the best way to
ship your orders can be frustrating and
confusing shipstation makes it quick
easy and convenient you can easily
import orders from any sales channel you
can automate just about any shipping
task so you spend less time sorting
through orders and more time doing what
you do best they also integrate all
selling channels on shipstation into one
simple dashboard so you can seamlessly
connect carriers print shipping labels
and get products out the door over a
hundred thousand sellers use ship
station for their business and they're
working with all major carriers that
give you exclusive discounts on ups usps
and more you can compare shipping
carriers with the best solution for you
and your customers so with ship stations
small businesses can now access the same
rates usually reserved for fortune 500
companies without the contracts it's
never too early to start prepping the
holiday rush so get a head start with
shipstation for our listeners you can
use code toast to get a 60-day trial
just in time for the holidays that's two
months of stress-free holiday shipping
for free go to ship
station.com click on the microphone at
the top and enter in toast
ship station make ship happen great well
enjoy the interview hope you guys
enjoyed this episode and we will see you
tomorrow you know what we forgot to do
yesterday i know an emoji we were in
such a rush no and we had like so much
[ __ ] to do yesterday i think the gavel
to signify all the justice that could or
cannot be served in the next few weeks i
completely completely completely agree
gavel on our most recent instagram if
you made it to the end of this episode
and enjoy porsha she's a gem check out
her book she's also doing a book signing
at barnes noble on fifth avenue tonight
so if you're in the city and you want to
meet porsha she was really a gem and
like she takes fire pictures so check it
out enjoy the interview and we'll see
you guys tomorrow for home day bye